bonsoir soir ça va bien sur les marchés
ça continue de bien aller 15 à 20%
d'augmentation depuis le début de
l'année comment ça s'explique
mais les résultats on a des bus une
année où les marchés étaient
relativement bas l'année dernière ça
avait été dû s'installer sur la bourse
américaine s and p 500 dans un gain de
22 % puis entre autres c'est que les
résultats continuent toujours dépassé
les attentes ce trimestre fait pas
exception alors on va regarder tout de
suite un graphique que vous avez apporté
aujourd'hui pour montrer que l'évolution
des profits des entreprises du site un
lead and poor's 500 sont un peu chargé
là mais ça c'est au troisième prix
visent depuis 1998 les entreprises qui
dépassent les attentes à chaque
trimestre oui ce sera donc à chaque
annonce de résultats bien ici on voit
que 73 % des sociétés ont annoncé des
résultats supérieurs aux attentes des
annonces puis ça c'est assez frappant
parce que c'est pour montrer trop
souvent non exactes pour monter en 2006
pour avoir le même degré de résultats
donc ça nous dit quoi de savoir que 73%
des entreprises qui dépassent les
attentes
qu'est-ce que ça signale de l'état de
santé des entreprises l'état de santé de
l'économie américaine
mais la chose qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est pourquoi le marché a réagi
positivement puis pourquoi que les
résultats sont sont dépassées c'est déjà
la barre un terrain relativement basses
qu'on réalise c'est finalement la
situation n'est pas si pire qu'on le
craignait
avec les tensions géopolitiques en
particulier entre les états unis puis
puis la chaîne
donc c'est vrai que les résultats
avaient déjà visé à la base ce jeudi que
la barre avait baissé même chose pour le
prochain trimestre au début de l'année
on s'entendait qu'au dernier trimestre
de l'année les résultats
elle est en hausse de 7% puis
aujourd'hui on annonce des hausses de -2
1% donc encore au prochain trimestre
probablement les équipes de direction
vont dépenser les attentes mais pourquoi
on fait des projections si faible si on
pense qu'ils seront meilleurs que ce
qu'on projette pas ce qu'on voit dans le
marché actuellement en partie au secteur
manufacturier
on a des indicateurs qu'un
ralentissement dans le secteur
manufacturier
puis aussi l'aspect d'imprévisibilité de
la réaction du consommateur avec tout ce
qui se passe dans les médias la de les
tensions géopolitiques peut-être ça peut
même affecter des habitudes de
consommation ou du moins les
investissements des entreprises c'est
clair quels sont les secteurs
vraiment qu'ils vont très bien ou qui
ont les entreprises ont présenté
d'excellence ce qui va très bien
résultat la technologie ça a été super
positif 5 ans des soins la santé elle
vous demander ce qui va bien ce qui va
beaucoup moins bien c'est ce qui est un
poids c'était secteur de l'énergie c'est
ce dernier trimestre depuis le début de
l'année c'est difficile aux états unis
et au canada
est ce que des entreprises qui se
démarquent qu'on parlait d'amazonie à un
instant amazon dépasse les attentes
oui amazon publié d'excellents résultats
puis tout a envie de voir la non ce qui
se passe au québec que c'est le réflexe
qui se passe en amérique du nord
amazon au dernier trimestre dépenser 10
milliards de dollars pour optimiser sa
logistique parce que sa promesse pour
l'année prochaine c'est de livrer à
travers les états-unis probable au
canada pendant 24 heures aucun
maisonneuve vraiment l'objectif de
forger un avantage compétitif dans le
monde en ligne
c'est sa rapidité d'exécution en termes
de livraisons ça c'est évidemment ça va
raccrocher consommateur et l'entreprise
a toujours un potentiel de croissance
même si c'est la plus grosse de tout
maintenant
mais si on regarde ces catalyst peu de
gens réalisent que exemple le vecteur de
profits pour amazon son service de
nuages à w est ce dernier trimestre
cette division a généré des profits 9
milliards en grosse modo les profits
générés par les divisions rentables sont
canalisés vers des projets pour forger
l'accord entre elles puis la cause sa
compétence dans le secteur du commerce
électronique aide aux entreprises qui
vous viennent à l'esprit qu'ils sont
marquantes en ce moment 2 2 qui vient à
l'esprit il ya des signes qui publie ses
résultats hier à disney doublé son
nombre un degré de ses dépenses pour
vraiment aller dans son vainqueur de
télédiffusion avec disney plus on voit
vraiment la profondeur de son catalogue
pour être vraiment intéressant
d'observer parce que disney son avantage
non seulement elle va pouvoir diffuser
son catalogue qui est important mais a
pu rentabiliser des certaines émissions
par la vente de marchandises tout le
secteur du divertissement des parcs
thématiques puis ce que netflix a pas
donc on va voir cette bataille là dans
les prochains trimestres
comment ça va se dévoiler les résultats
un autre société qui marque
instrumentation c'est facebook facebook
depuis le début de l'année résiste oui
exactement
malgré toutes les tensions politiques 8%
mans le
d'autres noms d'utilisateurs quotidiens
aujourd'hui 1.8 milliard de personnes
qui utilisent l'une des plateformes par
mois 2 facebook et ses ventes sont en
progression de 29%
c'est phénoménal oui c'est quand même
exceptionnel comme comme comme situation
là on vient de parler de quelques
entreprises amazon et facebook qui
domine vraiment l'économie mondiale en
ce moment l'économie américaine mais
certainement l'économie mondiale est ce
que le marché carbure à la baisse des
taux et à la politique monétaire
accommodante de la réserve fédérale
c'est une bonne question parce que je te
rassure c'est un enjeu si par exemple on
voit qu'il ya calédonie manufacturière
continue de savoir bien c'est négatif en
tant qu'investisseur mais l'autre côté
parce que ça veut dire c'est que
première réserve fédérale vont
intervenir à nouveau puis on a vu
comportement du marché ça a été a été
applaudi je voyais qu'un ou en une
quarantaine de banques centrales
accommodante dans le monde autrement dit
qu'ils baissent les taux qui ont des
politiques monétaires accommodantes
oui puisque ça fait entre autres c'est
qu'aujourd'hui environ 13000 milliards
de dollars d'obligations qui ont des
taux d'intérêt négatifs
donc à mon avis c'est tellement
difficile de trouver du rendement dans
la liquidité ou les obligations qui est
probant les marchés boursiers vont être
encore intéressant pour les prochains
mois merci mon plan merci merci beaucoup